عليكم ان تعدوا العدة ولتستعدوا
للقادم جيدا. هكذا صرح بها بوتين
ليعلن بعدها عن ادخال الة الموت
للخدمة. بينما يحدد الرئيس
الروسي اهدافه العسكرية لعام
الفين وثلاثة وعشرين. فهل يتجاوز
سقف اهداف الاراضي الاوكرانية
هذه المرة والامريكان يتجاهلون
تحذيرات موسكو ويمدون كييف بسلاح
خطير. ستنتظر ردا روسيا عنيفا
اذا قامت بهذا الاجراء والمانيا
تنشر اسلحتها بالقرب من روسيا
فكيف سيرد الروس. الهند تتحضر
لحرب الصين. واوروبا تعيد النظر
بخصوص بكين. بيونج يانج تعلن
التحدي امام العالم. واميركا ترد
بنشر المقاتلات والقاذفات بجوار
المجنون. والاتراك يتسابقون
للتفاوض مع سوريا. فمن سيصل اولا
والجزائر يحقق ايرادا تاريخيا
ودول الجوار تطالب بحفظ سيادة
العراق. واشنطن تتحدى موسكو. خطر
المواجهة العسكرية يقترب شيئا
فشيئا. وامريكا لا تتوقف عن
استفزاز الروس ما يجعلنا اقرب من
اي وقت مضى لمعركة طحن الرؤوس
والعظام. حيث كشف رفيع في
الادارة الامريكية ان الرئيس
بايدن سيعلن عن حزمة مساعدات
جديدة لاوكرانيا بقيمة ملياري
دولار تتضمن صواريخ باتريوت
وقنابل دقيقة. بينما كانت موسكو
قد حذرت واشنطن من هذه الخطوة
متوعدة بان تلك الاسلحة هي اهداف
مشروعة. فهل يقف الروس عند هذا
الرد فقط? بالتأكيد لا. فقد دار
بوتين سريعا ليحدد موعد ويجتمع
بكبار قادته العسكريين خلال
الايام المقبلة من اجل تحديد
الاهداف العسكرية للعام المقبل.
ليعترف بوتين ان روسيا اليوم
تحارب جميع دول الناتو. مؤكدا ان
امكانات وقدرات الجيش الروسي
تزداد بشكل متواصل. بينما وزير
الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شويجو يؤكد
ان ضباطا من الناتو يعملون في
منطقة العمليات العسكرية
باوكرانيا. وان من خمسمائة قمر
صناعي تابع لواشنطن والناتو تعمل
لصالح اوكرانيا. لكن استعداد
الثالوث النووي الروسي يضمن
تحقيق التوازن الاستراتيجي وفق
تعبيره. فيما عاد الرئيس الروسي
مؤكدا انه يجري الاستعداد لتحقيق
جميع اهداف العملية العسكرية في
اوكرانيا. ولماذا كل هذه الحدة
هذا هل هو التحذير الاخير? ليس
ذلك بل ان بوتين اعلن ان صواريخ
سيركون التي لا مثيل لها في
العالم ستدخل الخدمة في يناير
القادم. واول اهدافها قد تكون
اليونان. التي اعلنت وزارة
دفاعها انها قد تستغني عن انظمة
الدفاع الجوي الروسية اس
ثلاثمائة. والصحافة اليونانية
تقول ان وجهة الانظمة قد تكون
اوكرانيا بحكم تمرس قواتها
عليها. في وقت هددت فيه موسكو
اليونان علنا رد قاس على اقدامها
على هكذا خطوة مستفزة وعدائية.
وبالعودة للجانب الاوكراني فقد
انطلق الرئيس فولودو مرسيلنسكي
في اول رحلة خارج بلاده منذ
بداية الحرب وحط رحاله في
الولايات المتحدة يخرج المتحدث
الروسي ديمتري فيسكوف ويؤكد بان
موقف الرئيس الاوكراني لن يصبح
اكثر ايجابية بعد زيارة للولايات
المتحدة ولن شيء في عملية
التفاوض مع روسيا. بينما صرح
ضابط المخابرات الامريكي
المتقاعد ان واشنطن تستعد
لاستبدال الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي من
اجل وضع شخص اكثر ربحية في مكانه
وهو القائد العام للقوات المسلحة
الاوكرانية بحسب قناة جورجينج
فريدم. ولا زلنا في اوكرانيا
ولكن على الحدود مع روسيا اذ
حاكم بريانسك الروسية ان القوات
الاوكرانية قصفت بلدة سوزنكي
الحدودية مما تسبب في انقطاع
جزئي للتيار الكهربائي مع تضرر
للسكك الحديدة في المنطقة
بانتظار رد روسي عنيف بعد تجاوز
قوات كييف للخط الاحمر للروس في
حدود اوكرانيا ايضا تسعى المانيا
لتأمين جوار اوكرانيا وتتعهد
بتقديم منظومة مانتيس مانتيس
يمكنها اطلاق الف طلقة في
الدقيقة والتصدي للصواريخ
والمسيرات المعادية. من جانبه
قال وزير الدفاع البريطاني بن
واليس ان روسيا تعتزم منح ايران
مكونات عسكرية متقدمة مقابل مئات
الطائرات المسيرة وعلى ارض
المعارك في اوكرانيا. الدفاع
الاوكرانية تقول ان قوات موسكو
استطاعت تأمين موطئ قدم في مخموت
الروسية تعلن اسقاط ثلاث طائرات
ومروحيتين اوكرانيتين في دونيتسك
ومقتل مئات الجنود الاوكران خلال
اربع وعشرين ساعة. ليرد زيلنسكي
ان روسيا فقدت نحو تسعة وتسعين
الفا من جنودها في اوكرانيا
متوعدا موسكو بمزيد من الخسائر.
لكن الخارجية الروسية اتهمت
الاتحاد الاوروبي بمحاولة التستر
على جرائم الحرب في اوكرانيا من
خلال انشاء محكمة خاصة. الصين
تحير اوروبا. امريكا تستعد
والغرب يستعد وكل يتحضر لمواجهة
التنين الصيني لكن كل على طريقته
الخاصة. فالهند تستعد لشق طريق
بطول الف وسبعمائة كيلو متر على
طول الحدود مع الصين لتعزيز سرعة
الامداد العسكري لجنودها في
المنطقة. وذلك عقب الاخيرة بين
قوات الهند والصين. لكن الهنود
يفعلون ذلك رغم الهدوء والاتفاق
مع الصينيين. فمن الذي يذهب لحرب
الجارتين بالمنفاخ من الهند الى
اوروبا. حيث يعيد الاوروبيون
النظر في رؤيتهم الى الصين خلال
العام الجاري بعد انحيازها الى
روسيا في غزوها لاوكرانيا لكن
يبدو ان هذه النظرة السلبية قد
تتلاشى مع التوجه الالماني الى
التصعيد مع الصين. ليدعو الرئيس
الالماني شتايم ماير نظيره
الصيني شي جين بينغ لاستخدام
نفوذه للتأثير على بوتين من اجل
ايقاف الحرب. حرب اخرى تواجهها
الصين. لكن هذه المرة لا زال
اصحاب العيون الضيقة بعيدين عن
الانتصار. ووسط طفرة الاصابة
بفيروس كورونا ازدادت اعداد
الجثث فوق الطاقة الاستيعابية
للمحارق وجراس الانذار من جديد
خوفا من عودة التفشي السريع
للوباء. المجنون جاهز للرد
دائما. عندما يردون عليه بكل حزم
يجيب زعيم كوريا الشمالية ضاحكا
كالطفل الصغير لكنه لا يترك
افعالهم دون رد هنا وعلى وقع
التوترات المتصاعدة مع بيونج
يانج وبعد ساعات من اجراء كوريا
الشمالية تجربة صاروخية اعلنت
واشنطن عن ارسال مقاتلات وقاذفات
استراتيجية قادرة على حمل رؤوس
نووية لشبه الجزيرة الكورية بهدف
اجراء تدريبات مشتركة مع سيول
بحسب وكالة نيوز الكورية كتهديد
خطير لبيونج يانج ليرد المجنون
بتحد واضح لاي نداءات دولية بوقف
برامجه الصاروخية وها هي كوريا
الشمالية تعلنها. العقوبات
الاضافية لن توقف برنامجنا
الصاروخي. فهل فهمتم يا هؤلاء?
تركيا ما بين الداخل والخارج.
بينما ينتظر العالم الخطوة
المقبلة لاردوغان بين الحرب
والسلم مع سوريا يبدو ان الامر
ليس بيد الحكومة التركية. وبعد
حديث عن عقد لقاء ثلاثي يضم
روسيا وتركيا وسوريا تقدم حزب
الشعب الجمهوري المعارض بوعود
للرئيس السوري بشار الاسد شريطة
عدم الاستجابة لدعوة اردوغان
لعقد لقاء مشترك. ومن بين وعود
حزب الشعب ان تركيا ستلبي جميع
مطالب الادارة السورية بما في
ذلك التعويضات وسحب القوات
التركية من جميع الاراضي السورية
في حال وصل الحزب الى الحكم.
وذلك مقابل عدم الالتقاء بالرئيس
اردوغان حسب وسائل الاعلام
التركي. بينما الحكومة التركية
اشترطت انسحاب قوات قسد من منبج
وعين العرب كوباني وتل رفعت في
شمال سوريا كما طرحت عودة قوات
النظام السوري ومؤسسات الدولة
الى تلك المناطق اضافة الى حرس
الحدود مقابل الغاء العملية
العسكرية. لتذكر مصادر تركية
اخرى ان موسكو يمكن ان تقبل
بعملية تركية محدودة اذا اضطر
الامر مقابل معارضة واشنطن تماما
ليطلق وزير الدفاع التركي خلوصي
افكار تهديدا شديد اللهجة ان على
الولايات المتحدة ان تقطع كل
علاقاتها مع المنظمات الارهابية
والارهابيين حسب وصفه. الاحداث
والتطورات. في انجاز تاريخي.
صادرات الجزائر غير النفطية تحقق
اعلى مستوى سنوي منذ الاستقلال
باكثر من ستة مليارات دولار توقع
ان تصل لخمسة عشر مليار دولار
العام القادم. في مؤتمر بغداد
المقام في الاردن اكدت مصر رفضها
لاي تدخلات خارجية في العراق
بينما قال الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون
ان العراق يعد احد ضحايا عدم
الاستقرار الاقليمي. هيئة
النزاهة الاتحادية العراقية تصدر
اوامر قبض وتوقيف بحق عدد من
كبار المسئولين السابقين. في
الوضع يتفاقم بانضمام طواقم
الاسعاف الى الاضرابات التي
تجتاح البلاد ليتسع الخلاف مع
الحكومة بسبب رفضها زيادة الاجور
في خطوة صادمة. حركة طالبان تحظر
التعليم الجامعي للنساء في
افغانستان والامم المتحدة تندد.
بايدن الاتفاق النووي مع ايران
مات لكن لم نعلن عن وفاته. خرج
بوتين غاضبا كم لم يخرج من قبل
خلال الحرب الاوكرانية والغضب
يتفجر من عينيه موجها كلامه
للغرب والناتو. فهل حان وقت
المواجهة?